احتفلت روسيا بالذكرى الثامنه والسبعين
للنصر على النازيه وصفته النيورك تايمز
بيوم النصر الصامت لكن لماذا الجواب يظهر
في الغاء استعراض سلاح الجو الروسي لاسباب
امنيه وتقليص الاحتفالات في اكثر من 20
مدينه والغاء المسيرات العسكريه والشعبيه
تحسبا من اضطرابات داخليه وفق الصحيفه
ورغم ذلك استعرضت روسيا عضلاتها العسكريه
في الساحه الحمراء في موسكو حيث جلس رئيس
الروسي بين عدد من الضيوف الاجانب
والمجموعه من المحاربين القدامى وجنرالات
الجيش على منصه اقيمت للاشراف على العرض
العسكري الذي شاركت فيه وحدات عسكريه ضمت
نحو 10 الاف جندي ومئات المركبات والاليات
والانظمه الصاروخيه
[موسيقى]
في هذا اليوم الذي يعتبر الاحب الى قلب
بوتين شدد ان مواطني بلاده متحدون في
معركه مقدسه مع الغرب حول اوكرانيا وسوف
تنتهي بالنصر مشيرا الى ان مستقبل الدوله
الروسيه يعتمد على المشاركين في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا طبعا بعدما
شنت حربا حقيقيه على بلاده فلنستمع لمقاله
اليوم حضارتنا مره اخرى تشهد نقطه تحول
حاسمه وتندلع حرب حقيقيه مره اخرى ضد
وطننا لكننا قاومنا الارهاب الدولي سنقوم
ايضا بحمايه سكان الدومباس وضمان امننا
بالنسبه لروسيا لا توجد دول معاديه سواء
في الغرب او في الشرق كما هو الحال مع
الغالبيه المطلقه من الناس على هذا الكوكب
نريد ان نرى المستقبل سليما وحرا ومستقرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات